- Boutcha enterre en
ses morts. Certains exhumés des
fosses communes et e e e en
terre une deuxième fois.
D'autres retrouv
là où ils ont été tués
par les soldsssssssses.
VICTORIA KOPERIA
- Ça
la peine.
Aujoi,i,i,i, c'est mon ami,
il s'appelait Radiq,
il est musulman.
- Victoria nous explique queéééé
à son ami de rentrer en courant
chez lui, et ils ont tiré.
Ils l'ont atteint de plusieurs .
Et comme personne, dit-elle,'ar
chercher les corps pour
les enterrer, le sien
a été dévoré par des chiens.sts.
- Pour le maire de la ville,
les exactions des Russes ne font
aucun doute. Ses citoyens ont
Et selon lui, c'était planifié.
Penenenenenenenenenenenenenenes
des victimes dans une fosse
commune, le silence est pesant,
même s'il ne reste que quelques
ici.
Depuis, c'est à la morgue
travail d'enquête sur
c c c c c c crimes de guerre.
Des experts identifient
les victimes et déterminent
pour éventuellement traduires s.
Ce n'est qu'après un long
finalement remis aux familles.
leurs proches. Cet homme vient
vévévévévévévévérifier les lists
dans l'espoir d'y trouver
le nom de son frère.
"Cdidididididididit-il parce
qu'un mort doit être enterré.
C'est très dur pour sa femme."
Encore rien, ma
aujourd'hui. Bohdan reviendra
demain.
Plus loin, dans les rues
de Boutcha, t t t t t t t t été
terribles. La brutalité des
forces russes, particulièrement
appelle ici "la rue de la mort"s
après le retrait des Russes,ilie
la rue celui du mari
d'Irina Abramovaèèèèèèèèèèèèèèè,
selon elle, ont lancé
une grenade sur sa maison
et son mari voulait juste
essayer
"Ils  f f f f f f f f f f f f .
Ils l'ont emmené devant,
l'ont fait agenouiller,
lui ont enlevé son chandail
Irina voulait mourir, elle
aussi, mais elle a tenu malgré
parce qu'elle voulait récupérer
le corps dsésésésésésésésésé
dans la rue pendant un mois,
et le mettre décemment en terre.
qu'aucun des soldats venus ici
ne reparte c
Un sentiment de haine
imimimimimimimimimimimimimimimùs
personnes étaient enterrées
lors de notre passage.
"Pourquoi les Russes
les ont-ils tués? se
Victoria. Ils n'étaient pas
armés, ils ne menaçaient
des civils."
- Je détes
de mon pays détestent.
- Elle parle des Russes,
bien sûr. E
Victoria nous demande de bien
montrer tout ça, pour que
dans son pays.
(c                             e